do you think jeffrey epstein's still
alive
you know what lynn ward said some stuff
about that it went quite viral on my
channel
um in january and um
i wouldn't rule out that he's you know
he could be down on some island with
kenneth lay who's george
bush junior's biggest political
contributor at some point
you know really yeah yeah the guy behind
the enron
fiasco yeah was george bush's
single biggest contributor at some point
it's a crime family you gotta pay the
back sheets
to the mafia boss if you're running your
scams
when they're in the white house whether
it's the clintons
whereas the bushes it's the same old
tricks the same old games
and when kenneflay got arrested i think
i was in um
department of corrections i said to my
cell mate long island i said
this guy this is never ever gonna get to
trial
this guy was bush's biggest contributor
let's see what happens next and he just
died mysteriously didn't he was his
heart or something
really oh yeah he was abstined yeah oh
my god
yeah i mean well the epstein idea of him
the theory of him being still alive it
doesn't seem that far
out of the realm of possibilities
because if i'm jeffrey epstein
and i know people are trying to kill me
i know people want me dead because of
all this compromising information i have
on top
world officials on world leaders
my response is going to be if
i disappear or end up dead i have
contingencies in place that will
release all the information on all of
you
you know what i mean like like if
jeffrey epstein that would be i would
and i would imagine that would be one of
the top two things on his
priority list to have in place if he got
locked up
so how they get around that you know
what i mean they it seems like
the most logical answer is they faked
his death and he got out and he's living
on some island
or they seized that information
because they have the technology that's
so advanced that they would get that
and people i've interviewed believe that
they do have that and
galen's treasure trove already
and then they went in there and if you
look at the crime scene photo
there's electrical cord on the floor
they use that electrical cord
to strangle him and that's what caused
the damage to the hyoid bone
which is more common in homicide than
suicide
and then they strung him up to make it
look like a suicide
so i'm about ninety percent believing
the su
the uh he was epsteined and and ten
percent
um that he's on some island with kenneth
lay yeah but if even if they did get
that information off
off whatever off a hard drive let's say
how would they be able to how do they
know how many copies are out there or
how to destroy
they would have to destroy the other
evidence after they got their copy of it
all right so let's say that epstein was
working
for the intelligence community as a
honey trap and his boss was wexner which
is what maria farmer
the victim has said then if epstein was
just a mid-level manager
in that operation wexner was the
victoria's secret guy
yeah okay yeah um
he was the uh what's the other company
as well
um i can't remember it off the top of my
head
was it victoria secrets um
[Music]
anyway yeah i think it was very sorry
secrets yeah was one of them
um so if wexnet is is you know
the boss of this honey trap operation
and he's clicked up with the
intelligence community and epstein was
just a mid-level manager
then i think that information could be
contained by the intelligence community
yeah i mean i don't know i feel like it
wouldn't be too hard for him to make
copies of stuff
and distribute it you know to have just
something in place to
to save his own life yeah but if you had
the information
you just saw what happened to epstein
what would you do with it
i would go leave it on the doorsteps of
the new york times
or something like that you know somehow
yeah without streets camera'd up isn't
it
they will i would be [ __ ] my [ __ ]
pants that's what i would be doing
yeah i guess but if epstein i mean you
would think that epstein would do
something to to pay those people to to
figure out a way to get that to the
public you know
anonymously i don't know i think it
would have happened
if they had their balls to do that and
they had information i think someone
would have
released something yeah i think it's
been contained
because they've got all the money and
all the technology in the world against
little players so nothing's gonna happen
to her
maxwell will do some prison time because
she's gonna have to
[ __ ] otherwise um everyone's gonna just
say there is no [ __ ] justice in the
world how can this woman
right who trafficked hundreds or maybe
thousands of victims and participated in
sexual assaults
get a pass because she's buddy with
prince andrew and bill clinton
right she's gonna have to do something
and the lawyers are gonna say like
you know that this is so serious these
charges are serious you've got to do
some time
it's just how much she does
it's a so are you every day online just
like keeping track of every document
that's filed
[Laughter]
[Music]
i can't even take a break the minute i
try and take a break
there's breaking epstein news it's the
case that never goes down because
there's so many people involved
and it's spreading jean-luc burnell
maxwell
oh the other guy i forgot to mention was
was peter nygard who was doing these
pamper parties
he was drugging girls up taking their
passports and raping them anally
after been you know promised these jobs
as as models
and whatever again another good old pal
of
prince andrew he's been down there on
the island
and this guy's own sons
are in the indict charging him
with sexual they were sexually abused
the dad
thought it was a good idea a rite of
passage
to have a sex worker [ __ ] his teenage
sons
so that they were no longer virgins
oh my so he bought a hooker for his kids
yeah wow how old were they
they were in like the i think the middle
or low teens
oh my god yeah and how is this guy
connected to epstein
no he's not he's connected to prince
andrew gotcha he had
his he had an island down there near
where
epstein's island was as well
uh in that you know part of the world so
he was another
bahamian billionaire and um
[Music]
in charge of a massive um
company let me just look it up again
you'll have heard of it
out of canada i believe i wonder what
they're doing with jeffrey epstein's
island okay so they got this thing where
they're trying to give up to get the
compensation to the victims
um well they said they'd just run out of
cash
so the island the island is to have to
be you know
um liquidated if they want to keep
paying these victims
and and the lawyer fees that are ongoing
holy [ __ ]
how much money they get for the island
oh well i can't remember how much it's
worth
last time i looked at the value of
epstein's assets has actually gone up
approximately 100 million since he died
now guards
nygard's visitors over the years at his
island included
michael jackson george h w bush robert
de niro
and prince andrew what it's called
nygard k
nygaard k yeah yeah
um a fought in 1987 he built a 14 000
square
meter compound that lifted k in the
bahamas
past partly destroyed by fire on
november 10 2009
the k is inspired by the main
civilizations architecture
one of the major buildings is a 3 000
square meter grand hall
with a 45 ton glass ceiling
and this guy's still alive yeah he's old
now he's 79 and he's in prison
he was rated the 70th richest canadian
uh in 2009 with a net worth of 817
million and now he's in prison in the
u.s or
or where yeah he's facing extradition to
the us
okay okay yeah six allegations of rape
made against him
all under 16. well i interviewed ryan
dawson who just got the platform from
youtube
and he was talking about how they were
just taking these girls passports and
drugging them up
and sodomizing them jeez who is this guy
ryan dawson you said
yeah ryan dawson he's he's out of japan
he's a good guy he's an activist
why did he get the platform um
too many these kinds of videos
[Laughter]
you'll have to ask him that i'm not
exactly sure what uh he got his strikes
on what what videos
oh my god i'd love to see a podcast with
uh
david ike and alex jones oh we need that
don't we i mean
i think they have done some um
[Music]
they did a zoom i think or something
like that yeah there's something
there was something online but i imagine
that all got wiped out with the great
platforming
that would be absolutely bonkers